you know it's interesting that you with
this this woman that you talked about in
the beginning you talked about how she's
you know she's crouched down and she's
looking down at the ground and all that
so it's interesting in your rules
obviously the first the first rule is to
stand up straight with your shoulders
back right well when you get for lack of
a better word indoctrinated in fact
there is no better word when you get
indoctrinated in the military that's
exactly what's happening and guess what
you get taught one of the first things
that you get taught is how to stand how
to stand properly and you know what they
tell you
chin up chest out shoulders back
they make you stand like that there's no
coincidence to that is that you could
say it's a dominant stance but that's
not the right way of thinking about it
although it is a dominant stance the
reason to adopt it is not because it's a
dominant stance
it's a competent stance and competence
tends to make you dominant at least in
in hierarchies that are functioning
properly because you want there are
hierarchies which is what I outlined in
Chapter one I say though hierarchies are
old they're not socio-cultural
constructions they're not a secondary
consequence of capitalism and the free
mark all of that is absolute nonsense it
couldn't be more wrong and as an
indication of that I point out that
lobsters whom we diverged from on the
evolutionary front a third of a billion
years ago have hierarchies right and
that the neurochemical systems the
neural neurological systems that
lobsters have runoff that mediate their
hierarchical status run on the same
chemical that the neurological systems
that we use to mediate hierarchy run on
so that's just absolutely mind-boggling
but lobster like a victorious lobster
stretches out and adopts a more dominant
poles because his serotonin levels go up
as he becomes more and more victorious
and that governs posture well and so to
stand up straight with your shoulders
back is to open yourself up to the world
you're not in it if you're not in the
defensive Crouch of a prey animal
technically speaking and that is the
circuitry that's governing posture its
prey vs. predator or something like that
and an
to stand up like that is to expose your
yourself to the world but in a bring it
on sort of manner not not precisely
combative but let's say courageous and
your posture announces that and it
doesn't just announce that to other
people it announces that to yourself and
it can start it can be one of those
things that can start a virtuous cycle o
curry which is partly why it's taught in
the military get these guys that come in
they're all slumped over they don't know
how to stand up they're looking at their
feet their necks are bent like even if
they're good-looking men they don't look
good because they're all crunched over
you see people like this on the street
all the time they could be perfectly
attractive except they're completely
huddled in you know they need to stand
up and stretch themselves out and then
they can breathe too and that's a
competent stance